Okay, why is statistics useful in data science? There's a
lot of reasons, obviously. The, the, the first reason, I would
say, is, the most basic one and this goes back
to why statistics was, you know, developed a hundred or so
years ago. And it really is to make sure that
you're making reasonable inferences from data. So you hear a lot
of people talk about big data and the value of big
data and how we can you know, have data on just
about everything nowadays. And it's easy to get caught
up in that and it's important to remember, that
anytime, you're looking at any sort of data whether
it's observational or experimental. You want to make sure that
you're making valid inferences, right? You want to do things
like check for statistical significance, understand confidence intervals. Make
sure that you're not pointing you're working with in,
in certain conc, wrong direction because you've over interpreted
some data so I think that's the first,
probably most important reasons why statistics is important to
data science there's a lot more just working
with data, day in and day out there's a
lot of what I would call. Sort of,
you know very fine-grain technical skill, to just make
sure, you're doing the right thing, and you're
extracting the most information you can out of data.